this is a good night to be here at Tiff
big movie coming out it's amazing
um really special experience last two
days have been non-stop as you can
imagine and um
it's fun I think even with such a heavy
movie and a drama
this cast loves each other and he's
probably you'll see it tonight it shows
so it's a family yeah
it's been date night because she was
even taking pictures of you
was taking pictures um it's a proud
wifey it's cool it's cool to have her
here to support absolutely she looks so
stunning but did it was Nick best in
your chops because he's actually done a
military movie before you so was he
reminding you of that because he did
Midway with Mandy Moore of course he did
give me some some slack for that um but
you know it's cool to see that we all
can start to do our own things on the
side and be supportive as well he was
great in the movie and you know that
tells a different different world's
World story and this is um this is
focused on the Forgotten War of the
Korean War and one that I think we lost
a lot of people and
um this unbelievable story that I didn't
really knew existed with Jesse Brown and
how Jonathan brings it to life is is
phenomenal I mean this is a huge
opportunity for you Joe not that I need
to tell you but you had a cameo in
Zoolander too if I'm not mistaken yeah
this is a good quick Cameo I mean I I
cameos are fun but I've always had the
itch to get on screen and find a great
script that makes sense and work with
amazing people that can challenge me I
just really honestly a lot of it I
didn't have the time and I was great
grateful for them out of touring that we
did throughout these years but the
pandemic
um
gave me a little bit of window of time
to go out there and audition and put
myself on tape and and knowing I had
something to prove and JD giving me the
shot was was big Lynn loves a good
Fighter movie that's weird I mean look
he does he's good he's good in the air
he
that's why we're going that's why the
red carpet's so high up if you see
behind you Clan actually doesn't like to
do red carpets on ground level that
would totally make sense I'll have to
bring that up to him yeah and I gotta
say congratulations but how are you
finding being a family of four it's
amazing um you know genuinely um being a
dad rules and
um I'm a kid at the at the heart so
it's going well thank you
[Music]